alors vous avez une petite chanson oui
bah oui c'est vrai c'est la production
est venu me voir en me demandant si je
voulais écrire une chanson hommage pour
vous danserez tellement flatter m pour
nous deux ouais
je crois qu'il
faut quoi une guitare mais peut-être
mais la guitare
mais attendez une chanson en hommage
pour vous donc j'ai dit non et alors ils
ont vachement insisté monde ici allez ça
pourrait être vraiment cool et où donc
du coup moi j'ai été voir un petit peu
vos proches pour essayer d'avoir des
témoignages
mais d'après vos proches thierry était
tellement heureux et ému en pensant que
vous étiez mort
tu as du coup c'était pas possible de
comprendre ce qu'ils disaient et et
laurent n'a pas de proches donc bon
des centaines d'émissions des milliers
d'invités baffie ardisson toujours dans
nos télés les débats enflammés et des
fans en puissance trop souvent critiquée
je prends votre défense car vos trente
ans de carrière transmettre à nos
enfants et à la france entière un
message important
la drogue c'est mal pétrole cesse l
unisson devoirs et pour vos yeux
[Applaudissements]
de là
oui on va vous aider la drogue n'est que
souffrance la foule n'allait rien gagné
à part peut-être le
tour de france
mais il faut pour accrocher commencer
par l'acceptation et pour cela vous
devez vous poser les bonnes questions
[Musique]
jean luc delarue avait fait le tour des
lycées pour expliquer les dangers de la
drogue est ce pour les mêmes raisons que
vous faites le tour des bars à [ __ ]
la drogue c'est mal mais troque ses sera
lé
thierry vous avez gagné beaucoup
d'argent en écrivant le slogan vazyvaza
est ce que vous vous en êtes pris à
squeeze parce que gagner de l'argent
sans travailler c'était votre idée
est pas là m
laurent vous disent qu'il faut du cul du
cul du cul pour faire monter les
audiences mais si vous savez comment on
fait des audiences pourquoi votre film a
fait dix huit entrées
la drogue c'est mal et drogue ses salles
au bande de vieux réac de vos mères
allez crever arrête hugo caisse je
t'aime
c
en fait hier c'était le couple est
coécrit par christine angot
femme a expliqué qu'elle voulait vous
montré qu'elle savait écrire en verre
enfin j'ai pas j'ai pas tout compris
arrêtez vous irait mieux la cedrul ici
pas pensé y est pour vous deux
aujourd'hui
gr
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
leader des tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu